the best part of it for me is is
doing the new stuff that's like the high
point of the whole show for me David
Crosby has died he was 81 years old
we are together
the death of the founding member of
Crosby Stills and Nash was announced by
his wife Jan dance on Thursday in a
statement to variety she said quote
although he is no longer here with us
his humanity and kind soul will continue
to guide and Inspire us his legacy will
continue to live on through his
legendary music every day that I get to
go out and play music is an immense gift
Jan revealed David lost his life after a
long illness and was with her and their
son Jango at the time of his death Beach
Boys front man Brian Wilson reacted to
the sad news writing quote David was an
unbelievable Talent such a great singer
and songwriter a wonderful person I am
just at a loss for words don't take the
music business too seriously music and
music business are two completely
different things David Rose to Fame in
the 60s band the birds with hits like Mr
Tambourine Man and turn turn turn
later
there is
[Music]
but he found bigger success with his
next group Crosby Stills and Nash their
debut album has sold over 4 million
copies in the us alone featuring The
Classic track Sweet Judy Blue Eyes
[Music]
we generally sort of learn stuff you
know as we go along and get a little
better as we go along you know learning
stuff as a matter of fact if it didn't
sound better after 16 years they'd
probably fire me the band later became
known as Crosby Stills and Nash and
Young when Neil Young joined as their
fourth member Neil decided he wanted to
tour with crustace also Nash so the four
of us are going out and we're going all
over the country David was inducted into
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame twice
once with the birds in 1991 and six
years later with Crosby Stills and Nash
he survived by his wife and four
children
foreign
[Music]